what's really funny is if you look at
the the google network revenues so the
off-site google stuff the ads they run
historically a big chunk of google's ad
business
it's now just 600 million dollars more
in the last quarter than youtube so
youtube is about to surpass this
critical old piece of google revenue but
the youtube
gains were very impressive but i'm
curious what you made of the google
cloud
changes because revenue to good losses
declined i was pretty bullish about
google cloud and i don't know
how you i think that they hit a key
milestone which was
the cost of providing the service was
less than
the revenue the service brought in i
think they're still investing in it but
it's really hard to displace amazon web
services because
amazon has just got this relentless
march towards how
little margin they can have now we don't
have insight into each of the product
lines at amazon but the scale of that
business
is crazy but google's cloud is super
important for them to win
as well because if amazon just has the
biggest cloud in the world
and azure and google cloud fall too far
behind
yeah you can't you don't want a monopoly
in public cloud here's a question for
you jason can you talk to more startup
founders than i do which is saying
something i'm hearing tweets and i'm
carrying some complaints about aws
pricing from startups and
and maybe even some growth stage
founders people are just a little bit
dismayed at how much aws can wind up
costing them
is that going to help azure and google
cloud or is that just complaints and
it's not going to change much i think
this is ride-sharing drivers complaining
about getting paid where
it's never going to be enough everybody
always wants to raise so even when it's
a
double the minimum wage in the country
or it's 15 or it's 25 or they give
minimums
people are always going to ask for more
and in this case they're always going to
ask for a smaller cloud bill
you know they're going to be like this
is too much and if your startup grows
but they're not
this generation is not comparing their
cloud computing costs to buying servers
and racking them
yeah and just 20 years ago there was a
line item when you were raising your
three million dollar
you know seed or series a three million
dollar series a 500 000 in servers and
co-location facilities and yes when i
did mahalo we racked servers
and then at a certain point we're like
uh the cloud on the cloud we had so much
traffic
that the cloud charged based on the
amount of traffic you used
and when you have your own fiber line
you don't get charged for usage
and so all of those kind of things that
are now competing with each other
are going to ultimately drive us down so
it's i think it's much ado about nothing
and it actually gives azure
and google cloud ibm and other people's
clouds
the ability to compete it's a great
entry there it's the other thing that's
going to be interesting is
i don't know if you know about
serverless but there's this concept of
you can build these little
objects that run on the internet and
when somebody goes to hit a website it
fires it up they run the
execution and then it shuts itself back
down yeah and so this can cut down for
some tasks in computing ninety percent
so with software you're going to keep
seeing the software
race down the utilization on the network
which then
games the cloud um and the same thing
with storage
and other things getting cheaper so well
the growth of usage of these public
clouds is crazy google cloud grew i
think 54
year over year in q2 azure was 51 so
very close there i think aws was i
couldn't find the number i was just
looking for it i think it was 37 percent
but i think about how much total spend
we're talking about going to the public
cloud
just over the last 12 months in q2 it's
billions and billions of dollars
and thank you vcs for financing all the
startups that are currently
living off of it because it's going
great for the majors it definitely has
changed everything in terms of the
funding of startups you literally took
out 20
30 of the cost and the time would have
burned months of setup
and runway so really you could have as
much as a third or more
of your startups cost being the setting
up of your office space
and your cloud you start looking at that
and you're like wow you just put that
towards developers or
you can fund many more projects the 250k
check
with the two developer startup can last
them for two years so this just came up
i was talking to a startup actually here
in providence there are some
proud to report they might have my new
address yeah actually
that's what this founder told me he's
like even in my the floor of the
building we have a little office and
there's two more that are venture-backed
i was like okay good news
but i asked him how long his two million
dollar cd ground was going to get his
company like how much runway is this
and he didn't give me an answer in
months he said 20 to 25 product cycles
and i was like that's the coolest metric
i've ever heard someone probably two
weeks sprint or something three-week
sprint yeah who knows but i mean like
that to me shows that they're not
thinking about just running out of money
they're thinking about where they're
going to get to in terms of what they're
building and if i was an investor and
i'm not
i think that would jazz me because it
seems like playing offense versus
defense
it is pretty amazing when the
the clock ticking down is not making
your decision making delighting
customers is
and it really it is why when we
syndicate uh a deal to the syndicate.com
which is like
our previously was on angelus and now we
do it there yeah we specifically
we will only syndicate you if you have a
minimum of 12 months of runway
but we're looking more for 18 to 12 24
months and the reason we do that is
we tell them we want you heads down
thinking about the customer for at least
a year
hopefully 18 months so you don't have to
pop your head back up and raise money
now of course in this market we
literally had to
change our accelerator schedule i'll
give you some numbers on this
sure we have over 300 i've invested in
300 companies in the last decade i'm not
sure how many of them are exactly active
but
let's say two out of three so maybe 225
are still affect
we have 65 companies currently raising
money we're in the process of closing
out of the 225
out of the 225 one and three basically
and there were people who are closing
before that and people who are thinking
about raising money
but having that many in process i've
never seen
and it has broken our internal systems
because
when a fundraising happens you go to
your existing investor you have to get
them to sign off on it read the
documents agree and then decide do they
want to take their pro rata
with 65 that means every business day 20
business days a month
i've got to be making three or four
decisions a day and going over three or
four sets of documents the lawyers in
our industry
are now saying like we need four days to
return around documents we need five
days to turn around documents used to be
like we turn around documents in for two
days
no problem just give us two days maybe
three and now it's like give us a week
we got just wait i've never seen this
level of activity yeah you think
founders are doing well with
ample secondary in the markets look at
their lawyers because
the lawyers are doing fantastically
right now because everyone needs them
right about now at the same time which
means they have enormous leverage
and attorneys are not getting a summer
break and a lot of vcs are not getting a
certain way i'm supposed to be going on
vacation and it's i'm scared to death to
go on vacation because i'm just like
what's going to happen with all these
deals and where basically
we came up with a term that we my new
term of art with founders is
standing pat which is the term in
draw poker when you say oh i want two
cards i'll take three i'll take two when
you do draw poker like the old cowboy
poker not
hold them you would say i'll take two
cards you give two cards they give you
two new cards
standing pad is i don't need any new
cards so good we're just like we're
standing back we're good
we're not adding to our position we're
not going to lead this round we're just
going to stand pat and
i've had to tell companies that we may
have actually participated in or led
like we're going to stand pat
because we just can't get to this deal
are you concerned about your portfolio's
performance in the near future
jp morgan blackrock and others are
projecting
public equity returns of just three to
five percent over the next five years
analysts at bank of america urged
investors to consider real assets as
part of an inflation strategy so
where are the major players putting
their money endowments for yale harvard
and other top asset managers are looking
into
alternative assets according to
masterworks research
endowments over 1 billion are investing
55
more in alternatives on average if
you're looking for a very interesting
asset class that's
uncorrelated with the stock market it's
blue chip art masterworks dot
io sells shares in multi-million dollar
paintings by artists like banksy picasso
and warhol according to masterworks
contemporary art has appreciated 14
annually from 1995 to 2020.
outperforming other real assets like
real estate
and gold i just had the founder scott
lynn on the program again
uh episode 1232 for an alternative
assets roundtable and he shared some
great insights around inflation
appreciation more
go listen to episode 12 32
masterworks.io is a fantastic idea
and they're executing at a super high
level i think it's really genius
so sign up today at masterworks.io and
if you use the code twist you'll skip
their 30
000 person wait list see important
information at masterworks dot io slash
disclaimer